Please stop judging.
Please.
Just please stop judging.
It's just so obvious and clear
It's just so obviously clear
now that everybody's got a pen
now that everybody's got a pen and a paper
and a paper
It's a phone.
- it's a phone.
Now that everybody's got a pen and a paper,
now that everybody's got a pen and a paper
judgement is fucking flying
judgement is fucking flying from
every dimension, every angle.
from every- every dimension,
every angle;
Everybody's judging and
I'm just asking you please to stop.
everybody's judging and I'm just asking please to stop.
Share
Share, share, but build people up
- don't drag them down.
but build people up
don't drag them down.
Judgement coming from all angles,
in all streams, all the time, 24/7.
in all streams.
All the time.
24/7.
WHO THE FUCK ARE YOU TO JUDGE?
Who the fuck are you to judge?
WHO THE FUCK DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?
Who the fuck do you think you are?
I just am flabbergasted by people's inability
to realize the hypocrisy of their judgements.
I just am flabbergasted by people's inability to
realize the hypocrisy of judgements
They're gonna be exposed. You're gonna be exposed.
You're gonna be exposed.
Do you understand?
Do you understand? Don't judge!
Don't judge.
You can - you can judge in your mind.
You can judge in your mind. Let it fester. Let it articulate.
Let it fester a little, articulate
But be thoughtful. Don't be quick to judge.
But be  thoughtful.
don't be quick to judge
Look at yourself first.
Just because you may not be doing A,
Just because you may not be doing A you might be doing C.
you might be doing C.
Is there a difference?
One of the biggest weaknesses
One of the biggest weaknesses of all of us,
of all of us as people, as entrepreneurs,
as people, as entrepreneurs, as content creators,
as content creators-
is we spend energy
is we spend energy on judging someone else
on judging someone else
because we create a fake narrative in our head, in that moment
that makes us feel better
that makes us feel better.
If you're in a mindset where judging
and dragging somebody else down,
if you were in a mindset
where judging and dragging somebody else down
contributes to your happiness
- you've fundamentally fucking lost this game.
contributes to your happiness,
you've fundamentally fucking lost this game.
And I implore you,
And I implore you, I beg of you, I hope of you
I beg of you
I hope of you
that maybe this second
that maybe this second starts the process
of going in the other direction.
starts the process of going in the other direction.
Offense always beats defense.
Offence ALWAYS
beats defense.
This new world of communication
where everybody has the power to share.
In this new world of communication
where everybody has the power to share
Judgement of others is at an all time high
in its distribution, but my friends
judgement of others is at an all time high,
in its distribution,
but my friends this has been the way it always been from the get.
this has been the way it
has always been from the get.
Nothing has changed;
Nothing has changed.
Technology is exposing us.
Technology is exposing us. Not changing us.
It's not changing us
It's time that we look at each other
and understand what we really are,
and understand who we really are
and deal with the harsh, harsh, harsh truths
and deal with the hard truth
harsh, harsh truths
of some of our shortcomings and
judgement of others is a the tippy top.
of some of our shortcomings and judgement of others is at the tippy top
I look at so many entrepreneurs,
I look at so many entrepreneurs
and so many business people,
so many business people,
so many of you that watch me to try to achieve
and so many of you that watch me to try to achieve,
spend a disproportion 50, 70, 90% of their times
spend a disproportion: 50, 70, 90%
of their time JUDGING somebody else
judging somebody else
for that quick shot of adrenaline or happiness
for that quick shot of adrenaline
or happiness or that fake fucking BOOST
or that fake fucking "boost".
That they get stuck on and they don't break through.
that they get stuck on
and they don't break through.
I will not judge you
I will not judge you. You're you.
You're you.
I will talk about my truths.
I will debate you in the things I don't believe.
I will debate you in the things that I don't believe
But who the fuck am I?
Who the fuck am I? I am zero.
I'm zero. I'm nobody.
I'm nobody.
I will not judge you. You do you. Do it the right way.
I will not judge you. You do you.
Do it the right way.
Do it the way that will build for your legacy.
Allow it to be in a way that
Allow it to be in a way that when everybody judges
when everybody judges
that those 8 billion
that those 8 billion people judge you correctly
the way you wish they would.
people
judge you correctly
the way you wish they would
the way that would make your grand-kids proud
The way that would make your grandkids proud.
but I would spend zero of my moments judging,
But I will spend zero of my moments judging. ZERO.
And I implore you to do the same.
zero